Yamato or Carrot?
Bon Clay or Vivi?
Katakuri or Smoker?
The One Piece community absolutely loves to
debate potential candidates to join the Straw
hat Crew, so today we are going to rank them
all from the absolute worst fits to the ones
that definitely should already be a Straw
Hat.
One thing you may not know though is that
there are actually pretty strict requirements
about which characters get to join the crew.
These three requirements are NEVER broken,
and each member fulfills all three.
They are: 1.
Every straw hat has a tragic backstory. 2.
Every straw hat has a dream that can be fulfilled
by joining the crew.
And 3.
every straw hat must have an actual role on
the crew.
And just to show you what I mean, Chopper
was abandoned as a young Reindeer, then he
poisoned his friend, which is pretty tragic
if you ask me.
Next, we have Chopper’s dream, which is
to be able to cure any disease.
Then obviously his role is the crew’s doctor.
And these three requirements hold true for
every single straw hat, which means that some
of these characters we are about to rank would
make absolutely no sense to join the crew,
while others are actually pretty perfect.
Let’s kick this off with the absolute worst
candidate that fans thought might join the
crew because at number eighteen we have the
Gassy scientist, Caesar Clown.
Which yes, sounds crazy, but there was a time
that people thought he might actually become
a straw hat.
We first met him as the main villain of the
Punk Hazard arc, and of course he did some
awful things which we will never forgive him
for, like kidnapping children and experimenting
on them.
Later on though, he proved pretty helpful
to the crew, like when he helped everyone
escape Big Mom’s tea party.
So let’s just pretend that somehow he was
let into the crew, how would he fit as a member
of the Straw Hats?
Well, first of all we already know that Nami
would never get along with Caesar for kidnapping
and experimenting on innocent children and
creating weapons of mass destruction.
However, his usefulness as a scientist is
impossible to ignore.
He easily helped heal the poisoned minks on
Zou and he also helped Chopper improve his
rumble ball technology.
So yeah, he could be pretty handy to have
around, but he’s still a scumbag and the
crew will never let him on.
And just slightly above Caesar is another
former villain who has actually traveled on
board the ship multiple times, which is the
Swamp man Caribou.
And I promise, these candidates will get WAY
better as we go down the rankings, but Caribou
is another straight up evil dude who spends
most of his time trying to kidnap mermaids
to sell at the slave auction.
Which is pretty messed up, and should pretty
much make him an auto-reject to join the crew.
Somehow though he keeps ending up on the ship,
even after we leave Wano, which has led some
people to wonder if he could eventually join
the crew.
But for the purpose of this video, he would
honestly be pretty useful to have on the crew.
I mean his logia swamp powers act as a sort
of pocket dimension, so he could sneak the
entire crew into places they might not be
able to reach.
Beyond his Logia power though, he is pretty
weak and could probably be defeated by any
decent fight with haki, plus he has no real
role on the crew.
So, goodbye creepy swamp man.
The candidates are about to get WAY BETTER
though because next up is Gaimon.
And it has been a LONG TIME since we saw the
most beautiful afro in the story, because
Luffy, Zoro, and Nami stopped at his island
way back before they rescued Usopp’s hometown.
And now this happened over twenty-five years
ago, which is way before most of us were reading
or watching One Piece, but it’s pretty easy
to make a good case for Gaimon joining the
crew.
I mean at this point in the story, Luffy was
picking up a crewmate from every island he
stopped at, so it would be reasonable to think
Gaimon would join as well.
And with his love for treasure chests, Gaimon
would have been a perfect crewmate to be in
charge of the crew’s money and gold, so
basically a treasurer.
Besides that though, he is not really a fighter,
although maybe he could have been some kind
of powerful animal trainer???
Anyway, none of these candidates so far would
have affected the Straw Hat’s story much
at all, but that all changes with our next
candidate, MontBlanc Cricket.
Now when we first met Cricket, he was living
on the edge of Jaya, searching for the legendary
city of gold.
And while the Straw Hats eventually found
the golden city up in the sky, Cricket was
at one point considered to be a possible new
member to join the crew.
And honestly, he could perfectly fill a super
important role, which is that of the log book
keeper.
Because as we saw during the samurai Oden’s
flashback, it is super important for someone
on the crew to keep track of the crew’s
journey so that people who come after can
know what truly happened.
And well, the straw hats have never had that.
So if Cricket had joined the crew this could
have changed the way the entire world views
the Straw Hats.
For example, I can just imagine Cricket keeping
records of the crew’s adventures and those
records somehow being shared with the world,
so that everyone would know just how good
the Straw Hat crew really are.
And even though it didn’t happen, I’m
a bit sad that this chestnut-head dude didn’t
join the crew.
Which is the EXACT OPPOSITE of how I feel
about this next candidate.
That’s because Rebecca was heavily speculated
to be joining the crew during the entire Dressrosa
arc.
And honestly, there were a ton of characters
people thought might actually join the crew
during this arc, but Rebecca is the one I
always heard about most.
And even though she is a decent fighter with
her expert sword skills, she isn’t strong
enough to make a difference in any major fights,
and I’d even rank her below even the weakest
straw hats.
She also doesn’t have any clear role on
the crew, and we certainly don’t need any
more scenes of her crying since we had SO
MANY of those during Dressrosa.
Now this next candidate might surprise you.
Because this person is the first of many marines
who at one time we thought might join the
crew.
This is of course Koby, who was literally
the first person that Luffy met after setting
out on his adventure.
Now, Koby has changed quite a bit over the
years, but he is almost THE PERFECT straw
hat candidate if you think about it.
He has a tragic backstory where he was forced
to be a slave for years.
He has grown incredibly powerful, so if he
were to join the crew it could be as a strong
fighter like Zoro.
But it is actually Koby's determination to
pursue his dream of being a Marine Admiral
that will ALWAYS prevent Koby from being a
straw hat.
Because he is never likely to become a pirate,
and no pirate means no straw hat crewmate.
So sorry Koby, you’ll always be a friend
though.
And while this next candidate never fulfilled
the straw hat requirements like Koby, that
didn’t stop TONS of people from thinking
he would join the crew.
I’m talking about the jaguar mink Pedro,
who traveled with the Straw Hats to help save
Sanji during the Whole Cake Island arc.
And it was during this time that Pedro showed
off how useful a crew mate he could be.
He was incredibly intelligent, an excellent
fighter, as well as having a lot of knowledge
about the New World.
Plus, since he didn’t get to travel with
the former pirate king, Gol D. Roger, it just
made a ton of sense that he would travel with
the future pirate king by joining Luffy’s
crew.
Unfortunately, Pedro is the one character
in this ranking who could not join because
of death because Pedro made the ultimate sacrifice
when he blew himself up to allow the crew
to escape from Big Mom’s territory.
So while we don’t know if Pedro would have
joined the crew if he lived, he was definitely
a strong candidate while he was still alive.
Though while Pedro would be a strong addition
to the crew, there is NO ONE in this entire
ranking that comes close to the impact this
next candidate would have.
I’m talking about the former admiral, Kuzan,
who many fans hoped would eventually join
the straw hats after leaving the marines during
the timeskip.
Those hopes were ruined pretty early on though
when we learned that Kuzan had joined Blackbeard’s
crew, but man it would have been INCREDIBLE
if the Ice Logia fruit user became a straw
hat.
I mean he’s pretty much one of the top fifteen
or twenty strongest characters in the story,
so adding him to the crew would make future
battles WAY EASIER.
Just take the battle against Kaido, for example,
because I’d probably rank Kuzan ABOVE Luffy
before he had his Gear 5 powerup.
So adding him as a fighter on the crew would
be a massive help, since he could fight top
commanders and even clash with Emperors, which
is extra helpful because Luffy often needs
some time to rest during battles.
However, Kuzan doesn’t really have a clear
role on the crew and we don’t actually know
what his main goals are.
We do know that he joined Blackbeard, but
there are always theories that he is still
undercover for the marines, and on top of
that Kuzan has always seemed to be trying
to figure out what exactly it means to enforce
Justice.
So yeah, a fun idea to think about, but Kuzan
was never really likely to join, unlike the
characters coming up in the rest of the ranking.
We can’t say the same for Paulie though,
because during the Water 7 arc, he was most
people’s number one option to join the straw
hats.
I mean they were already looking for a shipwright,
which he is, and he was a decently strong
fighter.
Plus, I guess he has somewhat of a tragic
backstory, if you can count a huge gambling
debt as tragic.
But in the end it just didn’t happen.
I for one would have loved to see him on the
crew though for a few reasons.
One, his Rope Action is just an awesome skill,
even though it isn’t even a devil fruit.
Plus he is actually pretty modest when it
comes to women, like when he demanded Nami
put on more clothes, so he would have been
a nice contrast against some of the more perverted
gags from Sanji and Brook.
But even Paulie cannot compare to the mind-boggling
resumes of these next straw hat candidates,
and unlike every character in this ranking
you can join the crew by clicking that nice
red subscribe button to get more one piece
content just like this.
Man though, shoutout to our next candidate,
Kin’emon, because this man basically traveled
with the crew for almost FOUR-HUNDRED CHAPTERS.
He has been a major part of the group ever
since we first met him as this farting pair
of legs back in Punk Hazard all the way up
through the end of the Wano arc.
And being a samurai from Wano, he is a pretty
strong fighter who I’d rank around average
for the straw hats.
And we don’t even need to imagine how he
would interact with the crew because he was
with everyone for so long.
He is pretty much friends with everyone, and
it would have been great to have another swordsman
on the crew.
Though, if I’m being honest I am glad we
don’t have his pervy personality joining
the crew.
However, his dream of saving his homeland
has already been accomplished, so he doesn’t
really meet the requirement of having a dream
anymore.
That all changes though when we talk about
our next candidate.
Because Momo has almost all of the same qualifications
as Kin’emon except even better.
For starters, he traveled with the crew for
a long time just like Kin’emon, but with
his recent age-up in the story, and his OP
dragon devil fruit, Momo would certainly be
a powerhouse fighter to add to the crew.
And he even has a pretty solid dream of wanting
to explore the world, which means he could
be the perfect log book keeper, just like
his father was on Gol D. Roger’s ship.
So yeah, he made a pretty logical choice as
a straw hat candidate.
In the end though, he stayed behind as the
Shogun of Wano instead of joining the crew.
And I would actually say that Momo is an even
better candidate than our next potential straw
hat, but I just can’t get over the fact
of how much I would have LOVED to see Katakuri
join the crew.
Now, he was Luffy’s main opponent during
the Whole Cake Island arc, so you might be
wondering why people thought he might join
the crew.
The reason comes from the very end of the
marathon battle between Luffy and the donut-loving
mochi man.
Because by the end of this fight, Katakuri
had become a MAJOR believer in Luffy, so much
so that he even seems okay with Luffy eventually
defeating his mother.
And this fueled a lot of speculation about
Katakuri being a future straw hat, and honestly
he just seems like a perfect candidate to
join the crew.
He’s obviously a top-tier fighter on par
with Zoro and Sanji, and his chill personality
means he should get along with everyone pretty
easily.
His mochi devil fruit could also be an infinite
food source, so no more needing Chopper as
emergency food, and he could easily inherit
his mother’s dream of creating a world where
everyone can live free.
He even has a tragic backstory, although being
bullied isn’t quite the same as losing your
parents, so he basically checks off all of
the straw hat boxes.
Sadly though it looks like the closest we’ll
get to one of my personal favorite characters
joining the crew is him being a future ally.
Now, before we get to the top five Straw Hat
Candidates who should have joined the crew,
we have another super interesting character
with Marco the Phoenix.
And this fan favorite was high on everyone’s
lists of possible new crewmates when the crew
came out of the timeskip.
That’s because after the former Emperor
Whitebeard was killed and his crew mostly
wiped out by Blackbeard, Marco was a free
agent.
And similar to Jinbe, who did eventually join
the crew, Marco was already an ally, he was
an older character who knew a ton about the
New World, and he has one of THE COOLEST devil
fruits in the entire story.
So even though he doesn’t really fit the
tragic backstory or having a dream part of
the straw hat requirements, it was always
just so much fun to think Marco might join
the crew.
Similar to Katakuri, he’s a pretty chill
dude who has already spent time with the crew.
I bet he would especially get along with Chopper
because they are both doctors, even though
Marco cheats with his devil fruit, but that’s
alright.
And he would be an incredibly valuable crewmate,
with his ability to heal injuries, help the
crew escape with his flying, and of course
his top-tier fighting ability, which even
allows him to clash with admirals and top
Yonko commanders.
And while this next character isn’t quite
as powerful, she certainly had the fanbase
COMPLETELY SPLIT on if she should join the
crew or not.
I’m talking about the loveable rabbit, Carrot,
who played a HUGE role in helping the straw
hats rescue Sanji from Whole Cake Island.
Then she kinda disappeared… for like most
of Wano.
But we’re not here to talk about that!
We’re here to discuss her fit with the crew,
and honestly it’s pretty near perfect.
She was great at the role of Lookout during
her time on the Sunny.
Her quirky personality was right at home with
the rest of the crew.
Really, though, she doesn’t have a tragic
backstory or a big dream to accomplish, so
I guess we shouldn’t have been too surprised
when she didn’t join the crew.
And I have to admit, I’m far less salty
about Carrot not joining rather than the number
one character coming up on the list.
This next character though might be a bit
of a shocker.
That’s because now we have the marine Vice-Admiral
Smoker.
And I know what you’re thinking, this cigar-smoking
dude is still a marine, and he’s shown no
signs of joining the crew, but hear me out.
First, Smoker has shown up many times throughout
the story on islands that the Straw Hats were
also on, such as Alabasta and Punk Hazard.
And in each place, Smoker witnessed the Straw
Hats save the country while the Marines and
World Government were either powerless or
straight up didn’t care.
Now, that hasn’t stopped Smoker from climbing
the marine ranks, but no matter what Smoker
is always trying to help normal people and
do what he believes is right.
Which ironically enough, usually doesn’t
line up with the World Government’s way
of doing things.
So just wait because when the Government’s
dark secrets are finally shown to the entire
world, I wouldn’t be surprised at all if
Smoker decides he’s had enough and flips
sides to become a pirate.
Now, how does he fit with the Straw Hats?
Well, he’s already pretty familiar with
them due to their clashes in the past, and
as a Smoke Logia fruit user, he’s pretty
powerful already.
Plus, his dream of figuring out what true
justice is and how to achieve it fits perfectly
with the straw hats’ destiny to free the
world.
Though it’s true we don’t know if he has
a tragic backstory, and he has a pretty rough
personality that doesn’t exactly fit with
the crew.
But if we keep in mind that Robin also joined
the crew as a pretty closed off individual,
then I’m sure someone like Smoker would
also eventually open up to the rest of the
crew.
So who knows, if he’ll join later on, but
I’m not ruling out Smoker just yet.
Which takes us to the one character who I
don’t think ANYONE would EVER argue against
joining the crew.
And that is Mr. 2, Bon Kurei.
And wow, even without the tragic backstory,
big dream, or a role on the crew, this dude
has literally sacrificed himself for the Straw
Hats more than anyone else in the story.
He stayed behind in Alabasta so Luffy and
the others could escape.
He saved Luffy from death by poison in Impel
Down.
And THEN he let himself get captured so that
the crew could escape from the underwater
prison.
I mean, what a chad, and if anyone deserves
a spot on the crew, it is THIS MAN RIGHT HERE!
But even Bon Clay’s sacrifice was not nearly
as shocking as Vivi NOT JOINING the crew at
the end of Alabasta.
I mean, wow.
Everyone thought she was going to join!
Everyone WANTED Vivi to join because she got
along so perfectly with literally everyone.
But no.
She stayed behind to take care of her country.
Sad day, for sure.
But wow, she would have been perfect.
First, her mom died at a young age and she
was forced to go undercover to save her kingdom,
so she has a tragic backstory.
And I actually think she would make a perfect
Vice-Captain for the Straw Hats and could
even teach Luffy more about leadership.
Which might have helped in later arcs like
with the family feud between Luffy and Usopp
in Water 7.
Unfortunately though, her dream was always
to save her country, which was basically already
accomplished.
So besides traveling with her friends, she
didn’t really have a solid dream to follow
by sailing with the crew.
So as sad as it was to see her not join, she’s
always been an honorary straw hat in my book.
Which means we now HAVE TO discuss THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL Straw Hat Candidate.
Yamato.
Or I mean, Oden.
No, wait, is she back to Yamato?
Anyway, she came on stronger than any other
character by straight up telling the crew
that she was going to join them.
And honestly, Yamato checks all the boxes.
Her father imprisoned her for basically her
entire childhood.
She would be an excellent fighter and log
book keeper, just like her idol Oden.
And her dream is simply to explore the world
after being trapped by her father for all
their life.
So yeah, I thought, and pretty much most of
the fanbase thought, that she would join the
crew after Wano.
Luffy even wanted her to join, but for some
reason she decided at the last minute to stay
behind.
However, if Yamato were to join, I think she’d
fit right in.
She is certainly goofy enough to get along
with the crew’s silliness.
Plus her devil fruit is just so awesome.
Love the icy-wolf powers.
In fact, it is one of my all time favorite
devil fruits, but even Yamato’s fruit isn’t
as overpowered as some of the most creative
devil fruits that could break the one piece
world, and if you want to see exactly which
fruits I’m talking about, you can watch
this video right here.
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.